poi non avete idea non ce l'avete hanno
fatto un frank che io ho visto vi giuro
su dio ho visto un secondo e ho tolto
perché ho detto casi cifalà reaction un
ragazzo ho scaricato dei miei video
appreso la voce mia da questi video poi
ha chiamato un sacco di persone e con la
mia voce ha fatto dei premi telefonici
eccome geniale strag regionali siete
ragazzi se io devo fare devo devo fare
la regione sta 9 in poi è bellissimo
vado ragazzi è uno che ti urla venate di
ragazzi a trappole ti rispondi
buongiorno perché io voglio crepes alla
nutella
no credo non le facciamo mi dispiace ma
sto scherzando infami un panino con la
nutella subito e quando viene qua lo
facciamo si fila in cucina
immediatamente preparami ben noti
sculazzo manco fosse l'ultima cosa che
faccio cioè noi siamo dei di champ sei
donna quindi in cucina subito e con chi
tar lo chiamo bernardo bernardo che
bernabe di dove sei bernardo sono di
torino bello che preserva la mia
identità vi sono chiamato bernardo non è
che ha detto famiglia non sarei mai
stato in grado di fare uno scherzo del
genere ve lo dico del network bernardi
26 bernardo sono di torino mi da alcun
numero di telefono così una volta che
fatto il panino ti richiamo leggo io
avrei mai fatto non avrebbe avuto le
palle di fare un video così i giovani
come fai finta di aver sentito va beh
non importa se mi dai il numero di
telefono quando ho fatto il panino che
richiamo farmi un panino con la nutella
subito al chilo dopo e da mangiare
lo devo consegnare o deve venire o devi
venire su a prenderlo io voglio crepes
alla nutella
ma le critiche non le faccio quindi se
vuoi le crepe di richiamare qualcun
altro un po di schweppes la tonica
andremo un po di schweppes
[Musica]
io sto qui per lavorare vendere panini
non per caso ma ti droghi
no mi sa che sei tu che ti droghi a far
effettuate dicendo perché tifo più bella
casa allora terme lo dici a me dai del
lei per favore mi ha detto di tutto tipo
ti droghi nome del genere se presa male
perché non avevo dato del lei ma come ti
devo confessare una cosa io ti amo si
produ bella caccia non me ne frega
niente di quello che ti amo e che deve
farci tu sei molto bella perché più per
vendere panini stimo è un panino con
anche generare la mia bellezza saperi
che si è proprio bella utenti siccome tu
sei una ragazza io sono una ragazza
prima di uscire no non sono qui per
un'attività commerciale sono contendente
io sono un ragazzo se tu sei una ragazza
possiamo noi facciamo l'amore con di
sapore queste non sono prestazioni che
cosa
[Musica]
via veritate vorresti il mio numero di
telefono dopo succedendo non ci voglio
credere l'aria non ci posso credere come
tu sei una ragazza io sono una cosa
chiara di uscire chi è che fasti video
vermi lo giove che lo abbraccio
voglio la reaction di parigi è arrivata
zio ma come faceva non farla dì la
verità che vorresti il mio numero di
telefono dopo avrà visto quanto sono
sexy non ho le dico anzi sto scherzando
ti stavo prendendo per il culo il cui
lei doveva andare a trovare la free gj a
distanza di sain martin garrido che
sottofondo toto ma dobbiamo andare a
trovare la free gj perché praticamente
avevo trovato una specie di cioccolata
chiamata free gj free gigena roba
stranissima e questo non è questa non è
un ufficio informazione mi dispiace
dovete chiamare l'ufficio del turismo
chiedo alle informazioni sulla
cioccolata devo chiamare l'ufficio del
turismo val barchetta se il turismo di
cioccolando seguiti wonka scusate
ragazze mi sembra che voi avete molto
tempo da perdere io no quindi vi saluto
e vi prego di non richiamare mai più no
ma a questo punto ma tenendole affanculo
in chigi s'è visto s'è visto
grazie
[Musica]
benissimo
ragazzi segnare
era una cosa geniale che ci avrei mai
pensato di fare una roba del genere
perché con lo sconosciuto ma chi è
martin harris sei fatto però signori
abbiamo il video definitivo tra tutti
però hanno pronto saluta rocca ma caro
visto che abbiamo mangiato bene oggi
voglio difendere la keys
in india ci stai bene perché
cinghialisti ultima chiamato numero
piedi tutto il bene che c'è arabo cave
ragazzi perdonatemi servito era
abbastanza veloce però c'è meritava la
visita reaction quantomeno c'è stato
fantastico però che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi grazie avermi consigliato queste
reaction consigliate vene altre di cose
che vedete in giro [ __ ] questa era
veramente [ __ ] e niente ragazzi con 100
se vi è piaciuto sul momento e mi piace
anche ai vari social che come
evidenziato sensi di sederci vediamo
questo video da ragazzi sanno di merda
busta di kiss non vali niente fai schifo
è veramente parla con l'anonimo perché
travestì le palle ci incontrassimo
sgombro
si incontra con gravi con orari con ora
ci incontra piccoli ci incontra
[Musica]
no